you on a Windows Phone no I don't
actually no no we don't no no really
this is the reality of the smartphone
market Google's Android holds close to
85% of the global market and Apple 12%
meanwhile Microsoft Windows Phone holds
a measly 2.5 percent and it's been on
the decline you'd think it's because
windows phones aren't as good as the
others but the software has been
improved and so has the hardware just
today the best design Android phone the
HTC One is being released with Windows
Phone which gives it just as much or
even more functionality than Android
phones or the iPhone so really why don't
more of these people own a Windows Phone
first let's dismiss the idea that
windows phones aren't as attractive or
well designed as the iPhone or the best
Android phones because this m8 is a real
pleasure to use exactly like the Android
model it has a 5-inch 1080p screen with
a beautiful thinner aluminum design
there's also a high resolution ultra
pixel camera with a second lens so you
can refocus the photos after you take
them the photos aren't as good as the
ones taken with the top Windows Nokia
phones but I still prefer the sleek
design at the HTC - Nokia's colored
plastic so all things are equal with
hardware software must be the problem
right nope live tiles show core
information without having to open an
app and the new Notification Center puts
new messages in closer reach it also is
easier to create folders right on the
tile screen and toggle between apps I
didn't miss my iPhone or Android phones
email calendar or web browser and
believe it or not I didn't even miss
Google Maps and Cortana Microsoft's
answered a serie and Google now without
prompt she suggested places to eat and I
really liked her location-aware reminder
feature not to mention her nice soothing
voice do you love me Cortana
there's definitely a spark between us
but we're windows phones still struggles
to keep up with iOS and Android is with
third-party apps yes you'll find all the
big ones now everything from Facebook to
over to Instagram but because there
aren't as many Windows Phone users app
makers don't pay attention to it as much
as iOS or Android
for instance Instagram still has all the
usual filters but it lacks the editing
tools that were just added to the iPhone
and Android so why don't more people
have Windows Phones
well because more people don't have
Windows Phones no really that's the
answer because if more people did then
software developers would create more
apps for it if you're willing to go
against the crowd the HTC One m8 with
Windows Phone is a really good phone but
if you're worried about missing out on
all the latest apps and services then
you're going to want to be like the rest
of these people hold on to that Android
or iPhone